the aspect of when you do something like
joker
or like albert sparma you're spending
time in kind of a dark place
the materials the research you know can
start to have an effect on you know it
can
start to creep into your dreams at some
at some point
how does it feel to get so much award
chatter first
uh a great performance in a movie like
the little things and you were
in that movie you know denzel and um
you know it was just you morphed into
that character
how do you how do you feel about all the
recognition oh it's incredible i mean
uh first of all let's just talk about
denzel washington for a second
one of my heroes i mean i don't know
what it is about him
in particular that i keyed into as a
young actor but
i always wanted to see what he would um
what he was going to do next
you know and i get like from glory to
now
he's just and even before that and i
guess in st
house where you and all that stuff he
was always he's always he's always great
um he always surprises you and for me
i've watched his career with great
interest because i think he's one of the
few
actors that has really had that much
consistency
and really um he really puts his
his full body and heart and soul
into every performance that he does so
this film
was like just the denzel of it all was
was enough reward for me and
enough to make me want to say yes to the
project
i i feel like you just described
yourself though because you play these
characters that are so complex you
surprise us every time
you bring us something different you
know what is it that
goes into your work to that you can
change you're like this chameleon who
can like peel off the layers
performance anxiety probably you know
just now i always feel like uh
the harder that you work um the greater
the deeper the reward and the deeper
the uh the more you learn and
i love a good challenge so for me i
found that
transformative roles transformative
opportunities have been kind of a sweet
spot for me it really
it really is uh taught me so much about
um
really just about life in general but i
i enjoy taking on a role that's a huge
challenge a role that's a problem to
solve
mm-hmm hey how much of um your music
your
filmmaking as a man behind the camera
and and then being in front of the
camera you have all these different
little pots that you pick in that does
that play into your different characters
and how you approach different projects
well i think that everything you do
probably teaches you about everything
else that you do
and um i learn a lot as a musician it's
a really
tactile thing you know i mean you could
see a guitar behind me that actually
wasn't
placed there that was just an accident
and uh but you know it's
it's something that's a really
um it's a regular part of my life i'm
always writing songs
i've spent a lot of time standing on
stages around the world and
that teaches you about communication
teaches you about
creativity i suppose so you know i
learned a lot from that and then i'm
able to kind of take a break
from film for a while and then come back
with
you know kind of renewed excitement and
passion and uh you know uh i feel really
really
lucky i'll tell you to be able to do
these things really
really really lucky i want to ask you
about
what you're shooting now and i we don't
know a lot about this movie
and your character what can you tell us
about character working with gaga and
what's going on in
italy yeah i guess we should say that
i'm in i'm in
rome now uh and
uh working on uh the house of gucci
the gucci film uh that the the the one
and only ridley scott
is directing again one of my favorite
directors ever with just this
cast that i i'm blown away to be a part
of i mean there's
uh lady gaga or as i uh call her
lady gaga while i'm there um
but the queen uh herself and you know
just a terrific
creative person and the great actress
and
adam drivers in the film again um uh
just a phenomenal actor
al pacino jeremy irons and on and on and
on it's just a
stellar cast so i feel really lucky to
be a part but it it's the story of gucci
which a lot of people i didn't really
even know and i work with
closely with gucci for many years now
but it's a wild one
um are you and gaga thinking about any
music together
i think that we're so probably both of
us are so
buried with the work in front of us like
you know
the guitar is getting lonely over there
uh i picked it up but i felt like i was
cheating a little bit on my
uh on my uh character work and we're in
full prep mode right now
um you know usually this is a time that
i get really quiet before a film but
like i'm so thrilled at the response
really honored about
the little things reception and the fact
that people found
you know they found something in albert
smarma that that was compelling um
that was uh uh and that's just a great
feeling you know it's a great great
great great feeling and i just
uh again i'm just blown away tons of
tons of gratitude
well i think it's that you don't really
know without you know like
we never know that movie ends you never
really know about albert and that's the
beauty that you built in these
complexities that made it feel like
everyday real life where you never
really know you see these guys and you
say
killer not killer yeah you don't know
yeah there's a lot of ambiguity and i
think that's what makes it
challenging and special and it was wild
to play for me
um you know i dove pretty deep it was a
very physical
challenge big physical transformation uh
you know i had uh there was a lot going
on but it was
it was really i had a blast as well it
was it was dark
at times a bit tough uh psychologically
took its toll spending a lot of time on
the darker
side of the universe with you know fbi
transcripts and talking with people who
live this day and day out and you know
kind of getting inside the mind of
of of people uh that
have committed crimes and things like
that but
it it was uh it was a wild one man
um you went pretty dark with the joker
and we're gonna get to see a little more
of the joker now in the new justice
league series because
you weren't in the movie but now they're
gonna bring those scenes
back um how is that and what will we see
and how
how dark how much darker do you go
it was it was uh you know i was on
lockdown for so long
uh uh you know it was like a secret i
had to keep for so long it feels funny
to even talk about it uh
you know i was really excited to work
with zack snyder
i've been a fan for a long time and he
just
knows that world like nobody else i mean
he may know it better than anybody
because he's such
he's so he's in so deep with it and for
so many years
and he cares so deeply about the
character he cares so much about the
fans
and to me again it was i was happy to
kind of
be a part of his journey and and
retelling that story and telling it the
way that he always dreamed of
and uh you know it was it was fun to dip
my toes
uh dip my toe into that character again
and
uh to work with with zach and and
company
do any of these characters i mean how do
you shake these characters off
how do you because you go dark and you
get into it how do you shake them off
well i mean it sounds it's always a
funny thing to talk about because it
sounds a bit bizarre
but i would explain it like this
anything that you make a habit of
like i'm going to be speaking with an
italian accent in this film
right which is a lot of fun obviously
but if you do it enough
you it starts to um you know it it
becomes a habit because really just
you're retraining your mouth
and your muscles and your face and stuff
and so sometimes habits take a little
while
to wear off there's also the
aspect of when you do something like
joker or like albert sparma
you're spending time in kind of a dark
place the materials the research
you know can start to have an effect on
you know
it can start to creep into your dreams
at some at some point
and and you know for anybody that's like
binge watched
uh you know how to make it how to make a
murderer one and two or you know a
certain point you're like you need a
break
you play and you morph into all these
characters but sometimes do you just
want to be
you and do people you know get to ever
see
you the real you know
i don't think i would know what to do
i'd have to i have to learn how to i
have to approach
it like uh like a character
part um it's a good question and i think
in morbius
uh we'll get to see a little bit closer
to
you know how i speak day in and day out
how i move a little bit more
i mean that i'm super excited that
that's the marvel
sony project it's a brand new marvel
character has never been on screen
before
so that was a blast and i play a doctor
who's searching for a cure for his
disease was very sick and frail and at
the edge of
his life at the end of his life and uh
and then he gets strong
and healthy and then he there's
monstrous aspect as well so
um that i'm psyched uh about two but
but yeah that would be nice a little
rom-com on the beach in
hawaii or 29 palms you know where
that's okay too and a little rock
climbing a little hiking
laughs jokes
[Music]